[Music]
ASAP Rocky is Rihanna's biggest fan at
the 2023 Oscars I'm still pinching
myself really I'm grateful I'm grateful
a singer who's pregnant with their
second child gives a moving performance
of Lift Me Up The Ballad from Black
Panther wakanda forever
[Music]
me up
down
this means a little different to have
the impact that that song has meant to
not only our culture but just to a
global phenomenon which is Black Panther
ree's performance earned a standing
ovation from the crowd and from her bow
who is grinning ear to ear as he cheered
her on I'm trying to enjoy it as much as
I could the song serves as a eulogy to
Chadwick Boseman who played King
t'challa AKA Black Panther in the first
film
the actor died in 2020 after a private
battle with cancer he was just 43 years
old
[Music]
we're just deeply thankful that uh it
this song exists that she and Tim's and
and of course Ryan and Ludwig came
together and created this beautiful
ballad that you know shows the beauty of
our brother and then she pays tribute to
it so the fact that it's here tonight
and it's nominated
I mean it's everything man what else
matters I don't know yeah it's a special
night for re not only is this her first
Oscars performance it's also her first
nomination for best original song
[Music]
it really feels Like A lot's happening
all at once it feels like motherhood
Oscars Super Bowl the award went to rr's
not to not to but there's no denying
Rihanna is having a year full of wins
foreign